if you want to hear a story about the
height of kleptocracy or maybe better
said the depths of cronyism currently in
charge of our country this is the story
for you
Donald Trump has confirmed that he wants
to host next year's g7 summit at his own
Doral Golf Club in Miami Florida this
would be completely unconstitutional and
this is not my opinion it's the opinion
of legal and political experts because
there's this thing called the emoluments
clause asked why he wants to do this
this is hilarious Donald Trump said well
it's convenient because it's close to
Miami Airport check out a visibly sweaty
sniffing and Confused Trump making the
case for this after arguing with a
reporter about what counts as a question
and then making himself a martyr for
willing to be President of the United
States take a look here we go question
for you on next year's g7 summit but can
I just clarify someone you said you
mentioned earlier today one question let
me do the clarification and then I get
to the question or no you talked about
wormholes with China and a breaking news
alert them to understand what
specifically were heard from China and
on next year's g7 you alluded today drop
several hints about Miami about Doral
and hosting next year's g7 at your
property what reassurances if any can
you give the American people that you
are not looking to profit off the
presidency well I'll tell you what I've
spent and I think I will in a
combination of loss and opportunity
probably it'll cost me anywhere from
three to five billion dollars to be
president and the only thing I care
about is this country couldn't care less
otherwise I wouldn't have done it people
have asked me what do you think it costs
and between opportunity not doing thing
I used to get a lot of money to make
speeches now I give speeches all the
time in order to get Zippo and that's
good and I did a lot of great jobs and
great deals that I don't do anymore and
I don't want to do them because the
deals are making a great deals for the
country and that's to be much more
important Doral happens to be with
Miami it's a city it's a wonderful place
it's a very very successful area of
Florida
it's very importantly only five minutes
from the airport the airport's right
next to her it's a big international
airport one of the biggest in the world
everybody that's coming all of these
people with all of their big entourage
is come it's set up so poor and by the
way my people looked at 12 sites all
good but some were two hours from an
airport some were four hours from a that
was so far away some didn't allow this
so they didn't allow that with Doral we
have a series of magnificent buildings
we call them bungalows they each hold
from 50 to 70 very luxurious rooms Trump
also very interested in racking up
minibar revenue during the g7 that's why
he wants Russia back in Putin's
entourage will show up to Doral in the
new g8 and they will just Oh Trump tons
of money because of all the vodka
consumption this is just so stupid and
so illegal completely unconstitutional
this would violate the emoluments clause
against a government official self
enriching by virtue of being in office
if Donald Trump was not president there
would be no discussion of holding a g7
at a Trump Golf Club this is a way in
which Donald Trump is self enriching by
virtue of being President of the United
States or potentially self enriching
Trump constantly sends signals to
foreign officials about where should
they spend their money
Trump has already racked up endless
violations of the emoluments clause and
this would be another one and the thing
with Trump is maybe it's a good thing
compared to corruption behind closed
doors although there's plenty of that
with Trump with Trump a lot of the
corruption is out in the open I'm
wondering is it possible that doing the
corruption and the cronyism out in the
open helps Trump get away with it in
some way if the g7 was at some secret
location and later it turned out that it
was Doral or mar-a-lago maybe that leads
to more outrage
and consequences then Donald Trump just
saying straight up the at my golf club
for all of the cow towing to and praying
to the altar of the Constitution though
I would love to just hear Republicans
say this can't happen this can't happen
but even though they fetishize the
Constitution it's actually a lot like
the Bible for them we've talked about
how a lot of Republicans are all about
the Bible but not really they're all
about the parts that are convenient for
them some things something about
abortion something something about gay
marriage because man lying with another
man or whatever otherwise who cares when
the Bible is not convenient for you they
similarly claim to be all about the
Constitution but it's only certain parts
right the Second Amendment and their
complete misinterpretation of it that
they are definitely in favor of for sure
the First Amendment for people they
agree with absolutely the emoluments
clause that sounds like something that
should only apply the Democratic
presidents and I'll tell you this if
Trump wants to do the g7 next year at
Doral or mar-a-lago or whatever he will
probably get away with it the way it
will go down is we'll hear it's about to
happen for month after month after month
outrage panels debates then it will
happen even though legal experts say oh
yeah this is clearly illegal it'll be a
week of corporate media panels about is
this impeachable is it not impeachable
blah blah blah
legal experts again will continue to be
united and say yeah this is illegal then
Trump will threaten to nuke a tropical
storm or something and everybody will
move on and forget about it and he'll
get away with it like he's gotten away
with everything else fiasco after Fiasco
cronyism swamped filling worldwide
embarrassments the media outrage cycle
chases it for their own benefit and then
we move on to something else when Trump
says let's bomb a hurricane or send
people back to [ __ ] countries or
whatever and there's a very good chance
I I hate to tell you this there's a good
chance this is not going to end in
January of 2021 with the inauguration of
a Democratic president there is a good
chance and we need to recognize
and we need to prepare mentally for it
because I don't want to see the crying
on November whatever 2020 if and when
this happens there's a good chance this
is going to go on until January of 2025
when Donald Trump will be 78 years old
and will be completing eight years as
president of the United States
be prepared buckle up because it may
well be happening that is sort of the
bulk wrapping up our g7 coverage
yesterday and today it has been an
extraordinary embarrassment half the
country thinks that it was some major
alpha-male victory of some kind for
Donald Trump but anybody who understands
sort of how the world works in basic
geopolitics and diplomacy understands
that this was truly the height of
embarrassment for our country make sure
you follow the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show we will
have a poll and other content related to
the g7 and while you're there follow me
at David Pakman I have posted a video to
my Instagram of a Portuguese dog now I
don't mean a Portuguese water dog I'm
not talking about the breed I'm talking
about a dog from Portugal named poo Liga
which means flea in Spanish or
presumably in Portuguese as well I'm
guessing who watches the David Pakman
show okay there is a Portuguese dog that
watches the David Pakman show daily and
I have a video of that dog on my
Instagram at David Pakman follow me
there we'll take a quick break much much
more after this